atop the tallest of Earth's Peaks dwell
the gods of Earth and suffer no man to
tell that he hath looked upon them
lesser Peaks they once inhabited but
ever the men from the plains would scale
the slopes of rock and snow driving the
gods to higher and higher mountains till
now only the last remains when they left
their older Peaks they took with them
all signs of themselves save once it is
said when they left a carven image on
the face of a mountain which they called
in Granick
[Music]
but now they have betaken themselves to
unknown Kadath in the cold waste where
no man treads and are grown Stern having
no higher peak where to flee at the
coming of men they are grown Stern and
where once they suffered men to displace
them they now forbid men to come or
coming to depart it is well for men that
they know not of Kadath in the cold
waste else they would seek in
judiciously to scale it sometimes when
Earth's gods are homesick they visit in
the still night the peaks where once
they dwelt and weep softly as they try
to play in the olden way on remembered
slopes men have felt the tears of the
gods on white-capped floor I though they
have thought it rain and have heard the
size of the gods in the plaintiff dawn
winds of Larry on in cloud ships
the gods are want to travel and wise
quarters have legends that keep them
from certain high peaks at night when it
is cloudy for the gods are not lenient
as of old
in otha which lies beyond the river sky
who once dwelt an old man avid to behold
the gods of Earth a man deeply learned
in the seven cryptical books of us and
and familiar with an aquatic manuscripts
of distant and frozen lamar and the
villagers tell of how he went up a
mountain on the night of the strange
eclipse
baaz I knew so much of the gods that he
could tell of their comings and goings
and guessed so many of their secrets
that he was deemed half a God himself
it was he who wisely advised the
burgesses of Allah that they passed
their remarkable law against the slaying
of cats and who first told the young
priests at all where it is that black
cats go at midnight on some John's Eve
bars I was learned in the law of Earth's
gods and had gained a desire to look
upon their faces he believed that his
great secret knowledge of gods could
shield him from their wrath so resolved
to go up the summit of high and rocky
have egg claw on a night when he knew
the gods would be there
ha egg claw is far in the stony desert
beyond half egg for which it is named
and rises like a statue in a silent
temple around its peak the mists play
always mournfully for mists are the
memories of gods and the gods loved hath
a claw when they dwelt upon it in the
old days often the gods of Earth visit
hath a claw in their ships of cloud
casting pale vapors over the slopes as
they danced reminiscently on the summit
under a clear moon the villagers of hath
x8 is ill to climb hath a claw at any
time and deadly to climb it by night
when pale vapors hide the summit and the
moon but barzai he did them not when he
came from neighbouring otha and the
young priests a tile who was his
disciple at all was only the son of an
innkeeper and was sometimes afraid but
bars eyes father had been a land grave
who dwelt in an ancient castle so he had
no common superstition in his blood and
only laughed at the fearful Cotters
barzai and at all went out of hath egg
into the stony desert
despite the prayers of peasants and
talked of Earth's gods by their
campfires at night many days they
traveled and from afar saw lofty hath
egg claw with his circle of mourn who
missed on the thirteenth day they
reached the mountains lonely base and at
all spoke of his fears but Baz I was old
and learn it and had no fears so
led the way boldly up the slope that no
man had scaled since the time of San su
who was written off with fright in the
mouldy necrotic manuscripts the way was
rocky and made perilous by chasms cliffs
and falling stones later it grew cold
and snowy and bars I and art al often
slipped and fell as they Hume done
plotted upwards with staves and axes
finally the air grew thin and the sky
changed color and the climbers found it
hard to breathe but they still toiled up
and up marveling at the strangeness of
the scene and thrilling at the thought
of what would happen on the summit when
the moon was out and the pale vapors
spread around for three days they
climbed higher higher and higher towards
the roof of the world then they camped
to wait for the clouding of the moon
for four nights no clouds came and the
moon shone down cold through the thin
mournful mists around the silent
pinnacle then on the fifth night which
was the night of the full moon bars I
saw some dense clouds far to the north
and stayed up with a towel to watch them
draw on the thick and majestic they
sailed slowly and deliberately onwards
arranging themselves around the peak
high above the Watchers and hiding the
moon and the summit from view for a long
hour the Watchers gazed whilst the
vapors swirled and the screen of clouds
grew thicker and more Restless buzz I
was wise in the lore of Earth's gods and
listened hard for certain sounds but our
Tao felt the chill of the vapors and or
of the night and feared much and when
Boz I began to climb higher and beckon
eagerly it was long before a tower would
follow so thick were the vapors that the
way was hard and though a tale followed
on at last he could scarce see the gray
shape of Boz eye on the dim slope above
in the clouded moonlight Boz I forged
very far ahead and seemed to despite his
age to climb more easily than a tile
fearing not the steepness that began to
grow too great for any saver strong and
dauntless man no pausing at white black
chasms that at all scarce could leap and
so they went up wildly over rocks and
gulfs slipping and stumbling and
sometimes all that the vastness and
[ __ ]
of silence of bleak ice pinnacles and
mute in granite steeps
[Music]
very suddenly bars I went out of a tiles
site scaling a hideous cliff that seemed
to bulge outward and block the path for
any climber not inspired of the Earth's
gods at all was far below and planning
what he should do when he reached the
place when curiously he noticed that the
light had grown strong as if the
cloudless peak and moonlight meeting
place of the gods were very near and as
he scrambled on towards the bulging
cliff and Litton sky he felt fears more
shocking than any he had known before
then through the high miss she heard the
voice of unseen barzai shouting wildly
in delight I have heard the gods I've
heard earth gods
singing in revelry on hath a claw the
voices of Earth's gods are known to pass
I the prophet the mists are thin and the
moon is bright and I shall see the gods
dancing wildly on hatha club that they
loved in youth the wisdom of bars I have
made him greater than the Earth's gods
I think inst his will their spells and
barriers are as not bars I will behold
the gods the proud gods the secret gods
the gods of Earth who spurn the sites of
man a Tao could not hear the voices bars
I heard but he was now close to the
bulging cliff and scanning it for
footholds
then he heard bars eyes voice grow
shrila and louder
the mists are very thin and the moon
casts shadows on the slope the voices of
Earth's God a high and wild and they
fear the coming of pass high how wise
who is greater than they
the moon's light flickers as Earth's God
starts against it I shall see the
dancing form of the gods that leap and a
howl in the moonlight the light is
dimmer and the gods
lost bars I was shouting these things a
town felt a spectral change in the air
as if the laws of Earth were bowing to
greater loss for though the way was
steeper than ever
the upward path was now grown fearsomely
easy and the bulging cliff proved scarce
an obstacle when he reached it and slid
perilously up its convex face the light
of the moon had strangely failed and as
a tile plunged upward through the misses
he heard barzai the wise shrieking in
the shadows the moon is dark because
dance in the night there is terror in
the sky for upon the moon has sunk and
eclipse for told him no books of men all
of Earth's gods there's uh no magic on
half a claw for the screams of the
frightened gods I've heard two laughter
and the slopes of ice shipped up
endlessly into the black heavens whither
I am plunging high at last
in the dead of night in the dim might I
behold the gods of Earth and now but how
slipping dizzily up over inconceivable
steeps heard in the dark alone some
laughing mixed with such a cry as no man
else ever save in the Phlegethon of
unrelatable nightmares a cry wearing
reverberating the horror and anguish our
haunted lifetime packed into one
atrocious moment the other gods the gods
of the outer hell's the guard the feeble
cuts of Earth look away come back do not
see do not see vengeance of the infinite
abyss that cursed that damnable pit
merciful God's of Earth I am falling
into the sky
and the zat I'll shut his eyes and
stopped his ears and tried to jump down
would against the frightful pool from
unknown heights there resounded on a
thick claw that terrible peal of Thunder
which awaked the good quarters of the
plains and the honest burgesses of hath
egg engineer and author and caused them
to behold through the clouds that
strange eclipse of the moon that no book
ever predicted and when the moon came
out at last a towel was safe on the
lowest snows of the mountain without
sight of the Earth's gods or of the
other gods now it is told in the Maldini
Kotik manuscripts that sanzu found note
but worthless ice and rock when he
climbed Ithaca in the youth of the world
yet when the men of all far and near and
hath leg crushed their fears and scaled
that haunted steep by day in search of
barzai the wise they found graven in the
naked stone of the summit a curious and
cyclopean symbol fifty cubits wide
as if the rock had been riven by some
Titanic chisel and the symbol was like
to one that learn it men have discerned
in those frightful parts of the necrotic
manuscripts which are too ancient to be
read this
they found barzai the wise they never
found nor could the holy priests at I'll
ever be persuaded to pray for his soul's
repose moreover to this day the people
of Earth are and near and hath ik fear
eclipses and pray by night when pale
vapors hide the mountain top and the
moon and above the mists on a thick
cloud earth's gods sometimes dance
reminiscently for they know they are
safe and love to come from unknown
Kadath in ships of cloud and play in the
olden way as they did when earth was new
and men not given to the climbing of
inaccessible places
[Music]
you